Wow I this this [ __ ] i cracking up at
this dude mr. Jared limos jared leto
[ __ ] of all time Wow 12 days ago I began
a silent meditation in the desert
we were totally isolated no phone no
communication we had no idea what was
happening outside the facility Wow good
for you there are you well that's so
cool well that's so cool Jared or did
you just don't just disconnect from
society for 12 [ __ ] days you know who
else can do that no one this is this is
what I'm talking about this is like a
way exaggerated version of me being like
I'm not stressed right now yeah
Jared Leto being like damn I just came
back from doing 12 days of not even
speaking to another human being because
I don't have to 12 days of not of just
being in the desert silent
that's so cool dude oh good for you
Jenny believe what's going on in the
world right now it's crazy I was just
out there just beating off in the desert
for a fortnight connecting in my I was I
was sitting in the desert raising this
the spinal energy in my lowest chakra
and bringing it to my crown chakra and
finding that thousand petal Lotus and
seeing you know the true creator of all
of this mm-hmm and I come out and I see
all this suffering
if we would just take more time to
meditate yeah we would have less of this
suffering you know what my first thought
was after coming out of this blissful
place this serenity energy I don't even
know if that's a word
but sorry who was that who farted during
my livestream anyways this serenity this
serenity energy please stop farting
there might be you for it very well
maybe I was not paying attention to my
bodily functions either during this 12
day silent meditation I kind of let my
body do exactly what it wants pissing
[ __ ] farting I just happened didn't
no no holding it in anyways I saw this
suffering in the world and that first
thought was damn that's crazy that's
what this is it's just him saying damn
that's crazy I'm like the most [ __ ]
just rich privileged way ever
you know it speaking of look you know
this was so good those celebrities say
so [ __ ] we got it I got a clown Vanessa
again speaking of celebrities they're at
it again yeah I got it I gotta get my
[ __ ] I gotta I gotta get my tweet off
over the podcast because someone deleted
the video so now my I don't get free
Klout anymore so this is the way hold on
before we started this is this tweet it
is this drill tweet oh it is with a
heavy heart that I must announce that
the celebs are at it again
indeed they are all right Vanessa
Hudgens gets on IG live and I [ __ ]
thought this is a deep fake man yeah
like the quality of the stream and like
her face like her face like seems like
it's like tracking with her head all the
way what does she like famous for again
she was a Disney yeah she's like a high
school music okay right okay all right
let's let's hear this [ __ ] yeah till
July sounds like a bunch of [ __ ] I'm
but like yeah totally it's a virus I get
it like ya expect it but at the same
time like I respect that even if
everybody gets it like yeah people are
gonna die
it's just terrible but like inevitable I
don't know maybe I should be doing this
right now so I had to get on Twitter and
say she sounds mad that coronavirus is
more popping than hurt who is it
yeah like yeah it's a virus and like
totally respect what it does totally
understand it's 24/7 work ethic totally
get it but like it's just killing people
yeah it's not that it's not like it's
[ __ ] it didn't do four seasons of
High School Musical let's just say yeah
like it's only been what it's only been
like a month like talk to me when it's
been at it for like a year maybe two
okay then you're like career is starting
but like as of right now it's like
getting way too much attention you know
you know how hard it is like keep this
[ __ ] up like once you're you know at
terminal velocity it's like I've been
doing this for like tenure Vanessa this
is about a virus yeah I don't know why
you guys keep talking about it oh my god
I get it
the virus is all I hear about right any
version is like you know there are other
things in science like more of like
global warming once you talk about that
yeah alright [ __ ] she got in tons of
heat for that yeah yeah she got cooked
again just so [ __ ] just sitting and her
her white just five bedroom house in
Brentwood probably [ __ ] oh yeah I get
fence no he's like and people are gonna
die but like like that's just like
Darwin you know I'm not but like other
people well but like it's inevitable
modern farmhouse with this [ __ ] a
vaulted ceiling yeah
this [ __ ] got a gym in her backyard
has all these [ __ ] tools to combat
the [ __ ] why has a storage unit filled
by some assistant three three stainless
steel stoves yeah in the kitchen Auto
disinfectant yeah she's on histogram why
like so what some people are gonna die
it's it's a virus people last time I
checked that's what they do
meanwhile there's some [ __ ] some
[ __ ] sysadmin and goddamn the [ __ ]
Tennessee sweating his [ __ ] head off
maintaining on the [ __ ] servers did
let her get on there and [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] nine says admins paranoid if
someone's got it yeah if I can sitting
there in a burning [ __ ] sand whatever
so so Dom dude unreal and then she
apologized I think yeah she was like
guys I saw it she's like guys I take
this seriously I'm inside like
definitely stay inside it's like no
that's not it I'm inside my 10,000
square foot house like like all I can
like all I find myself doing is going
from the basketball courts to the tennis
courts to the fridge and then back to my
theater room I was like all I can do so
I'm taking this seriously
this [ __ ] lives in a [ __ ] mall yeah
that's a nuts she lives in a [ __ ]
Home Depot she's talking [ __ ] right get
out of here dog
you